and you'll be
ready any second
okay good evening everybody it is now
one minute part six um
we are here uh for the virtual meeting
of stratford uneven
district council's planning committee my
name is councillor richards i am
going to be chairing the meeting this
evening um few housekeepings to start
with if i may um
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed and recorded for
publication on the council's website
and on youtube for later viewing members
you will have all received
the etiquette for virtual meetings in
advance of this meeting but to reiterate
a couple of points
please can you make sure that your
device is either plugged in
and charging or fully charged please
remember to mute your microphones when
you are not speaking and of course to
unmute them when you are speaking
uh if you could indicate in the chat bar
when you wish to speak
that would be great i will call you in
at an appropriate time
when invited to address the committee
please ensure your microphone is
switched back on again
and of course switch it off again when
you have finished
and if you could also please turn off
any devices to silent
or off entirely so that we don't have
any interruptions during proceedings
if for any reason you encounter i.t
problems causing you to drop out of the
virtual meeting please do
make your best endeavors to get back in
again as soon as you can
if you're unable to rejoin for whatever
reason you will have been deemed to have
left the meeting at that point
the meeting will continue provided that
we are still
correct uh we will put two numbers in
the meetings chat members for you so if
you do have any technical issues you can
call those and
get help getting back in again
uh for the members of the public i just
want to confirm that checks have been
made
in the presence of our solicitor and uh
and our officers
to ensure that all members of the
committee are in attendance and they've
confirmed
in the presence of the as i say the
council league law so that they can see
and hear all proceedings
we have a number of officers online with
us as well i will introduce them
uh for you now uh from our committee
services we have and banks
from our legal services with our
solicitor minamak and we have from our
planning service in no particular order
joe brooke sarah chadwick stuart
flaherty and robert parker gulliford
and our planning manager for this
evening is alice koznet alice i believe
you have a statement you'd like to make
yes thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking
thanks marvelous thank you very much
okay let's move into
our full agenda first of all apologies
for absence and could you
let us know if we have any apologies
german we've got apologies from
councillors adam and parry
fabulous thank you very much um do we
have any disclosures of interest from
our members if you can indicate
please in the chat
i will very quickly while i'm waiting
for members to type in um
clearly members will have noticed that
the first item that is uh
202203 ful as a significant
methodist church i am the ward member um
and i have registered to speak so at
that point uh we will pass over to
councillor kendall who will very ably uh
share the meeting
throughout that item counselor dixon you
have
a declaration uh in a similar matter to
yourself
chairman uh i will be speaking in
respect of
uh item seven on the agenda olive
cottage
where i have been consulted by the
applicants and i am supporting their
case this evening
i don't have any peculiar interest
myself in the decision
uh but certainly i have made up my mind
marvelous thank you very much
i see no one else indicating to uh
disclosure
any interest so we will move on to the
minutes can i have a quick
hands up or a nod or a wave just to
confirm that you're happy for me to sign
the minutes from
our previous meeting on the 21st of
october that is a full house of thumbs
up
fabulous let's move on to our
applications
um we have heard uh just now from
councillor dixon
about olive cottage in hockey heath
members you will have noticed
from your update sheet that there is a
revised
recommendation to defer the details of
which
are contained within that update sheet
um i am going to propose that we
do defer for those reasons
could i have a seconder please
indicate in the chat if you will
counselor kendall has seconded cancer
kendall do you want to
formally second it vocally please yes
more than happy to second chair thank
you
marvellous in that case we will move to
a vote on that
so i will start councillor richards four
thank you councillor fleming
catcher flaring for thank you
councillor kendall councillor kendall
four
councillor crum cancer crump for
councillor curtis councillor curtis for
councillor dixon
i'm not partying um thank you
councillor eddon that's reading for
councillor jennings councillor jennings
ball
councillor hensha seriffin council
hencher seraphin4
and councilman mills council bill's four
that's the anonymous chairman thank you
very much anne
um in that case uh committee therefore
resolves to defer application twenty
zero
one zero four eight ful olive cottage uh
for the reasons given in the update
sheets
okay let's move and then to our first
full application
to be heard it is the methodist church i
will relinquish the chair to councillor
kendall so council kendall whenever
you're ready please take over
thank you very much chairman right okay
let's go to item four found on page 11
of your agendas this
is application reference twenty slash
zero
two two zero three slash ful
snitterfield methodist church barely
road snitterfield
um the erection of a boundary wall fence
and hedging erection of timber cloud
equipment store etc
the presenting officer for this is
stewart stewart flatty are you
ready to go i am indeed chairman thank
you very much
over to you then thank you thank you
good evening ladies and gents um as uh
council has just indicated
uh this application is uh for
the erection uh of the boundary or
fencing hedging
and other enabling developments um for
the conversion of this building to a
nursery
um here we see the application sites
within
a buab boundary uh of centerfield
indicated by the black dots on this plan
here we see a satellite image of the
site
itself um indicated by the red
arrow we can one can see we're in a
quite prominent corner here of bailey
road
and the green in the heart of the
village
and here we have the submitted site
location plan uh clearly with the
application outlined in red
um we are washed over by the western
midlands green belt
uh in addition the site lies within a
conservation area and is also within a
designated ardent special landscape area
here we see the existing site layout
plan for what's currently in situ
on site i will flick a little bit back
and forth now with the proposed layout
plan
um one can see uh
primarily there is no alteration to the
actual
well actually there's no alteration at
all to the footprint of the building
um there is um tarmac's area here to the
front which is to remain in situ with no
more or no less
parking spaces than there is currently
um here we see
other day enabling developments such as
a sensory garden what is called here a
pram park here for the children a buggy
parking area
um here is where there is what is termed
external equipment store
um and the area of grass is to remain
as is here the boundary wall is to be
erected
along the green here and up to this
part here alongside the existing area of
tarmac so
existing proposed i appreciate there's
quite a lot of dark
gray and brown and dark colors on here
there's actually
areas of what's termed here resin-bound
pathways but there's no actual
increase in uh footprint of the building
itself
you can see on the roof plan and in the
other plan there are actually some roof
lights as well
proposed um here is the extent of the
boundary wall
uh it's one point 1.8 meters in height
from
top to bottom and here is an elevational
plan of the equipment store
uh one and a half metres in height
uh here we have a composite uh slide
showing the existing elevations as per
this is the primary front elevation uh
as you look at it from
the highway and here is the proposed
indicating the
uh addition of some roof lights
uh and similarly some other enabling
developments uh
to the side um likewise
here we have two more roof lights where
there are currently none
on the rear elevation um
we have now some photos of the site
itself here we are stood
um looking down a gentle slope down
barely road looking south
eastward uh here we are now stood to the
side of the church from the footpath
on the green looking in the opposite
direction clearly
uh one can this is a relatively recent
photo i should say you can see there is
erection of what is temporary mesh
fencing currently on the site
um and here we are similarly we are
stood um
looking at the area of hard standing
here's the front which is to remain and
the grassed area which is also to remain
um as is detailed in the agenda pack
members are reminded that as
this children's day nursery is in the
same planning use class as the existing
church
planning permission is not required for
the conversion of this church to a
nursery
the proposal seeks to accommodate
development for a local business that
will provide employment and services to
the local and white community
in so doing it brings a characterful and
prominent building exciting the heart of
the village back into use reversing a
small period of
decline um please refer to the update
sheet for a small correction
in the report um chairman the
recommendation is to grant page 21 of
your report
thank you
thanks stuart good report uh good good
presentation thank you
um let's go to our first speaker on this
one then please um
i believe we've got councillor elliott
from centerfield parish council with us
on the line
uh councillor elias are you there can
you hear me
yeah perfect hello welcome to the
committee tonight hello
hello we can hear you hear me yes we can
hear you
okay great that's wonderful hello thank
you for being here tonight
um right i'm not sure if you've done
this before effectively you've got
three minutes to speak on this
application um
we'll give you a warning in the last 30
seconds so you know to wrap up
and uh please do stay on the line at the
end for any questions the committee may
have
is that okay yeah that's fine thank you
in that case
cancel it over to you okay
this second application states that it
is only about permission for the
erection of a boundary wall
hedging under timber glad store and that
the existing building will be converted
into a nursery regardless of the outcome
but this application has to be
considered in the context of allowing
these alterations to the cartilage of
the building
by granting it enables and gives
official approval
to the children's day nursery in a
totally unsuitable and restricted site
in the conservation area
the boundary wall and hedging is needed
to enclose the small outdoor space
to enable the children to safe to play
outside and is a vital part in making
this business viable when judging this
against ndp econ 2
by allowing the boundary wall and
hedging it will have an unacceptable
impact on residential immunity
as the outdoor space will be in constant
use in particular for near neighbours
there will be lots of green
infrastructure in the conservation area
in that the outdoor space will be
enclosed
and inevitably covered with outdoor play
equipment and it will generate increased
traffic
this new application still fails
therefore to satisfactory
address the reasons for rejection under
1903219 full
ndb b63 parking states advancements to
be considered with regard to the context
of the site
there are only six on-site spaces
available for 12 to 15 staff
a limited capacity for parking on nearby
roads indeed
sdc's spd on parking stipulates one
space for each members staff
plus sufficient space for dropping off
and collecting children the parish
council are also concerned that the
current six on site spaces
partially ingress onto the pavement
blocking pedestrians and restricting any
safe spaces for drop-off
as recently as september 20 steadfield
primary school sent parents not one but
two emails
highlighting their concerns with
seriously unsafe and inconsiderate
parking
this local knowledge and recent
experience is far more valuable than any
desktop city
and the city needs to reconsider the
shortfall of parking against its own
adopted parking spd
ndp b1h does not support development
which could
exacerbate foul drainage capacity
problems the message church board is
flood zone 2
and the adjacent crossroads flooded this
september making their own impossible
it also resulted in houses directly
opposite on school road
being flooded with vile drainage the new
culvert has still not yet solved all the
problems they experienced
in this part of the village a new
children's stay industry with additional
hard landscaping
will certainly contribute to increased
service runoff and foul drainage
capacity problems in this area
ndp ne2 the protection of individual
species
bats make use of the curtains of the
building and if there's any loss of
green infrastructure
it could impact on them they should
always be protected
the recent flooding parking and traffic
problems referred to above
demonstrates the real problems in this
area and are therefore relevant to this
planning application
they should not be discounted as the
applicant suggests simply because they
were not all listed as grounds to
refusal previously
the parish council recommends refusal in
order to protect residential immunity in
the conservation area and ensure safety
for all the children
and parents using the facilities in this
location
thank you thank you
perfect perfect time thank you mr
practice thank you
um i'll ask uh any questions from the
committee please
i'll just look in the in the chat for a
second
detected at the signs okay i'm not
getting any questions in that case i'll
say thank you very much and i'll let you
go
probably best if you continue watching
on the um on the uh
on the live feed now instead of uh
staying on this method
okay yeah okay thank you lovely stuff
we can go there to our next speaker uh
objective this is a klaus
martinson please a local resident who's
objecting
are you there please sir
mr martinson
here we have in the chat we've got a
number of people i think in
mr martinson are you in the uh meeting
if you press star and zero to unmute
your microphone
star six sorry star of six apologies
thanks
thanks star six to unmute
give you another second mr martinson
star and six to one mute
germany please looks like he's in the
meeting oh yeah
we're not getting much from him i think
possibly if we have the next speaker we
can always come back to mr martinson
afterwards
i think that's possibly the best thing
to do um in that case uh
ms donick skinner on behalf of the
applicant are you there
mr skinner
right i think we have pause for a second
and see if we can get them back in i'm
going to have to ask somebody from here
i can can you hear me chair uh yes i can
who's that is that mr skinner
it is yes yes okay mr skinner could you
just hold on for a second don't press
anything i'm just gonna
i just need to ask um our legal
representative amina a question
very quickly mina um we're taking these
out of order which is usually okay
but in terms of the time allocation
do we give would we allow mr skinner the
full six minutes which would be
the total of what is allowed given that
we've not yet heard from
mr martinson can you advise me on that
please
you can hear me now oh hello is
in that case mr skinner apologies for
this this uh
back and forth mr skin i'm going to ask
you to hold just for a second so we can
go straight to mr martinson first in the
correct order
is that okay
okay thank you very much uh mr mr
martinson welcome to the meeting tonight
uh thank you for being here
um you will have three minutes to
address the committee
at the end of the three minutes we'll
give you a 30-second warning before the
end of your time
um but please at the end of your three
minutes do stay on the line because we
may have some questions for you
is that okay do you understand love yes
thank you mr martin over to you then
thank you
okay i was the following to be a matter
of record
i live next door in sound bank and i
oppose the application because
of the impact on traffic and parking
threat to bats birds screen
infrastructure
and our privacy the biodiversity impact
assessment is part of the application
since the batteries was found
it was a legal mistake to approve the
conversion to a home without a condition
to implement the bia report
recommendations
this time however the design inheritance
statement does
acknowledge the recommendations and
state that we believe this further
survey
can be conditioned on any approval
notice and all works will avoid the burn
nesting season
a message statement is added since the
back roof space will be used for storage
wcc ecology has also added that the
recommendations and the method statement
must be strictly followed
the planning officer disagrees with the
dhs
and wcc ecology the committee report
states that the wcc condition is not
quote an appropriate or reasonable
condition
end quote to make it worse the
applicants have been told that no work
impact the main building's loft space
however
supply drawing clearly shows that the
roof lights will penetrate this space
jack doors are nested in there and
possibly bats the law
is very clear on this point and referred
to in the bia if bats are discovered
then construction is done and without
following a message statement
then the applicants are breaking the law
so please reject the application to save
the protected species
if you were to approve then please add
conditions of strictly following both
the bia and wcc
recommendations in addition ask for the
main building loft space to be
surveyed and for the dhs to be followed
on nocturnal survey and all works will
avoid the burn nesting season
the applicants say they can do whatever
they want inside the building and that
traffic and parking should not be
discussed or considered by the committee
but this is contradicted by including
drawings and of traffic plan
as part of the application and it is for
enabling development for
to facilitate conversion to a nursery i
cannot see that they have identified a
loophole in the planning process
in any case the roof lights are part of
the application
and in the metal statement to protect
the bats
the proposal is to position a shed and
hard surface in a way that requires our
hedge to be
severely cut back the damage would
likely kill it
not only would we lose a hedge but this
would be a major impact on our privacy
and so would the noise from operation 7
30 to 6
30. parking is 30 seconds
about a third of the loan will be
replaced by hard surface and small
tweets will be removed
the application documents are so
confusing that if you were to approve
then you should list which document and
statement your approval is referring to
some examples is the nursery planning
for in excess of 57 children
no more than 57 or in excess of 70
children
are there no trees or hedges on the site
or on the neighboring site
or are there in the is the news site
outlined correct or will staff park on
the pavement
will the new heads be tall so it blocks
the view for traffic or kept low
if there's no great way i'm afraid i'm
gonna have to stop you there i'm very
sorry
please protect the application thank you
thank you very much if there are any
questions from the committee please
indicate in the chat at the moment
or start nodding you ahead no
in that case mr martinson thank you very
much for your time tonight it's greatly
appreciated
thank you thank you okay
we can then go to our final speaker mr
dominic skinner this time mr skinner are
you in the meeting
i am yes can you hear me chair i can
wonderfully
thank you very much for bearing with us
so mr skinner you will have
um six minutes which is uh a combination
of the previous two speakers in thailand
of course
so you'll have six minutes to address
the committee like the others we'll give
you a warning at 30 seconds so you can
wrap up
and please stay in the meeting for any
questions at the end that case over to
you
thank you chair uh before i begin for
clarity i'd just like to state that i am
a workshop county councillor
though i am speaking today as a
representative of the applicant project
architect
only and that some of the councils on
this committee are known to me
planning is an emotive subject but one
that must be decided on sound planning
reasoning alone
as recently as the first of july this
year a planning committee reviewed an
application on this site
its early application was refused for
two reasons
one potential impact on the immunity of
the occupants and the neighbouring
dwelling caused by proposed two-story
extension
and a potential impact on the visual and
landscape immunity of the area
and loss of green infrastructure
considerable debate took place at the
planning committee
it is extremely important to note this
application was not
refused on grounds relating to parking
and traffic
it was recognized at the committee that
proposed change of use of the building
did not need
time commission that the county highways
authority did not object to proposals
the county highways authority does not
object to the current application
furthermore it is important to
acknowledge that the early proposals
were not refused on grounds relating to
impact and character and appearance of
the conservation area
flooding and drainage ecology or the
need for the facility
these items along with those of parking
and traffic therefore
are not for consideration as part of
this application
i would like to ask the committee to
disregard references made to in
connection with these
when making their decision this evening
as already accepted by the district
council
planning permission is not required for
the change of use
of this building from a church to a
children's day nursery
further work has proposed affect only
the interior of the building
or do not materially affect its external
appearance and therefore
do not amount to development for
planning purposes
the only matters before this committee
this evening for consideration
are the erection of the boundary wall
and railings the erection of the timber
store
the provision of a new entrance ramp and
decking
no works are planned to the tarmac
parking area which is to be retained as
existing
further no works are planned on the
grass area and verge outside the pose
boundary wall
as stated the current proposals take
account the reasons for rejection
given by the district council as part of
the previous application
in particular the scheme has been
amended to emit the repeat the previous
proposed two-story flat roof extension
emit the all-weather play area in favor
of grass
and change the alignment of the boundary
wall and railings thereby increasing the
grassed area outside the proposed
boundary
maintaining green infrastructure the
admission of the previously proposed
extension
also reduces the capacity of the nursery
to no more than 57 children
the consequential reduction to the
number of staff
the admission of the previously proposed
extension directly addresses
and overcomes the first reason for
refusal
the use of the grass for play area
rather than artificial or weather
surface
addresses the second reason for ejection
as does the realignment of the boundary
wall
and the retention of a grassed area and
verge outside the boundary
the proposed dwarf boundary wall would
be consistent with other properties in
the locality
with low level hedging adding to local
green infrastructure
the proposed boundary wall design is in
keeping with the established character
of the immediate area
and is a sympathetic and appropriate way
of enclosing the proposed external play
area
furthermore to this the revised
alignment of proposed boundary wall
ensures that there would be no
obstruction to visibility for drivers
and pedestrians concerns raised over the
ecological impact of development
are something that the applicant has
taken extremely seriously
it's important to note there has been no
objection raised by the county ecologist
in conclusion i would like to further
reinforce the requirement for this
application
to be decided purely on sound planning
reasoning
those issues raised and dealt with by
the previous application
while still a motive do not hold any
weight during the discussions today
the committee must therefore carefully
consider that plan commission is not
required
for the change of use of the building or
to carry out works to the building
but the scheme has been amended to
address the reasons for refusing
the earlier application including the
admission of the early proposed
extension
and amendments to the length and
alignment of the boundary warning
railings
the county highways authority and
ecology continue
to raise no objections to the current
proposal and that there has been no
material change to the planning context
i submit there are no grounds to reviews
that refuse the current application
and therefore it would be classed as
unreasonable to do so
in light of this statement i hope
members of the planning committee
will now grant planning permission thank
you chair
thank you mr skinner much appreciated uh
any questions from the committee please
indicate in the chat
i don't think we have any questions it
looks like you've gone off lightly
so mr thank you very much for your time
tonight much appreciated thank you thank
you
thank you right we go to our final
speaker on this one
uh which is our award member councillor
richards
good evening thank you that's richard i
think you know the routine
i do indeed have five minutes over to
you thank you councillor kendall
members many of you will no doubt recall
a similar application of this site being
heard at planning committee b
during the summer where a number of you
made up part of that committee
the decision then was to refuse the
application as it was determined to have
an unacceptable impact
on neighbouring immunity specifically on
some bank house
including its overbearing impact on
those neighbours
it was also determined to have an
unacceptable impact on the visual and
landscape amenity of the area and would
lead
to a loss of green infrastructure
whilst the applicants have sought to
reduce the scale of their proposed
extension i am of the opinion that these
reasons for refusal still stand
you have heard from the owner of some
bank who has expressed his discontent
with the impact of the development
and that it would have on his property
and its immunity value
so i do not intend to rehearse those now
instead i want to focus on another
aspect that i believe is contrary to our
own policies specifically
traffic and parking impact whilst the
officer states in his report that the
previous committee decision did not
include a refusal on traffic and parking
grounds
members of that committee who are here
today will recall a very detailed and
robust discussion about parking
indeed those that attended the summer
site visit will recall that the issues
we had
tried to park to view the site despite
these con the concerns expressed by the
committee
uh in respect of parking and traffic
generations they were
they were very much steered away from
that as a reason for refusal
to my mind that was an error and you are
entirely within your rights to include
that as a reason for refusal
now specifically our own
adopted parking standards require one
space per one member of staff
plus sufficient space for dropping off
and collecting children
the applicant's own transport assessment
clearly states that there is a shortfall
in relation to parking that cannot be
considered acceptable
and the application should therefore
fail on those grounds alone
the transport statement suggests that
the nursery will accommodate 70 children
and 15 staff members
yet the design and access statement
suggests 57 children with associated
staff
assuming that staff requirements are
similar there is still
a huge shortfall less than half the
number required by our
by our own parking standards the
previous speaker has said that staff
numbers will be reduced we don't know
what to
let's suggest it's 10 there would still
be a significant shortfall in parking
provision
before one even begins to consider the
requirement for drop-off
pickup at parking the application should
therefore be refused on those grounds
the transport plan instead relies almost
entirely on on-street parking
for those of you that have visited the
site you will know that the required
provision simply is not
achievable whilst every effort can be
made to encourage the use of sustainable
routes to schools such as buses cycling
and walking
they can only be encouraged they cannot
be enforced
so with that and notwithstanding the
employment benefit the nursery would
bring
i would ask you to consider very
carefully the impact this development
would have both in terms of its impact
on neighboring immunity
as outlined by the by the owner of the
sum of sunbank its impact on the green
infrastructure
particularly the departure from our own
parking policy by virtue of the
insufficient parking provision
and the impact that it would have on
traffic safety both for residents
but particularly the young children that
would be attending the nursery and the
school opposite
and refuse the application on those
grounds thank you chairman
thank you councillor um do we have any
commit uh questions from the committee
for the ward member please
if you want to indicate in the chat
at this point i notice a number of faces
that don't seem to be
moving towards keyboard in that case
thank you very much councillor richards
uh
we'll move to the next part of the
meeting right in that case
uh points of clarification to the
federal committee do you have any
questions please indicate in the chat
i'll give you a moment excellent thank
you
uh council jennings you've indicated
thank you chairman yes i just wanted to
find out in about these park
car parking spaces and the adopted car
car policy um why wasn't that taken into
consideration
and in in this case
stuart thank you uh
thank you councillor um yes clearly we
are
of course aware that parking as it's
been touched upon both by all of our
speakers
uh so far this evening parking is
clearly a very sensitive issue on this
site
um we are in knowing certain terms that
there
that there is a conflict with what would
have been our adopted parking standards
um were this to be a new build um
the fact of the matter is um this church
as is currently in situ um
can be converted to a nursery uh without
any planning permission
um we are guided by the ofsted space
standards
um as it's been touched upon in the
applicant's
submission um they are allowed to have
up to
57 children and i can confirm there's up
to 12 staff
proposed that's less than last time in
the summer
um we have got the existing parking time
up to the front which is to remain in
situ with the same number of spaces
proposed
um we have had to make a judgment
obviously
as a department um we're in a highly
sustainable location in the heart of the
village in the boab
we are guided by technical reports
provided by the applicants both a travel
plan
and a transport statement detailing this
the scheme
um is otherwise has an acceptable impact
on highways and parking safety
we're guided by our um
independent external consult here at
county highways who've offered no
objection
to the proposed works um and
i thought it's incumbent upon us uh as a
department to then
put this to you obviously as members in
our report
with our recommendation that the
highways impact notwithstanding that
everything has been heard and said so
far tonight is
um deemed to be acceptable in that
context
thank you stuart so just so i can
confirm for clarity in a nutshell
the if this had been a new build then
the parking standards council richard
was talking to
talking about would apply but because
this is an existing building they don't
apply am i right and
understanding it um mostly correctly
i'll clarify slightly i think obviously
the conversion of this church to a
nursery is is not deemed to be
development
so this can be implemented as a nursery
so um
and the space thereof so i understand
that thank you i just want to be
absolutely certain in my mind thank you
um we'll move to council eden for the
next question
thank you chair i just wondered whether
or not i could just get a quick glimpse
of that
uh down the hill shot please from
stewart
of course give me one second
can you all see that uh image yes yes
yes
that's reading you satisfied uh i
am yes um yeah that's fine thank you
chair
thank you move to our next uh question
from councillor fleming
thank you chairman um the question i
have is
um how the uh
how it came about that the green grass
verge to the left of the building
is now going to be fenced off i'm sure
that must have been
um a wide verge for a reason i
visibility emerging from that junction
um but i just
wondered who actually owns that piece of
grass that they they are now fencing off
uh the the bit to the to the left hand
side of the building
because i actually attended the site
visit there um and the large green space
to the left
um actually appeared to be county
council land
and i'm just wondering how we're able to
just fence that off
and take it within the curtains of the
building
well councillor flying we should be
aware of the fact that
ownership of the land is not a planning
matter of course um
um do you have anything to add to that
actually
um i think exactly that cancer counselor
i would say also to say there is a blue
line
um indicating the applicant's ownership
uh on the on the plan
um highways are obviously aware of the
of the application offered no objection
okay thank you stuart council fleming i
hope that's okay
um we move to the next question uh
council mills please
thanks mr chairman um stuart uh could
you
um put a a photo of the back of their
their building um there's some room
flights there were they
originally there on the first
application i know that you've
they've been not going for that
extension on the back
were the roof lights there um this
application
they uh they worked there within one
second i would just
absolutely confirm that for you um
i can tell you there were actually more
roof lights proposed on the last one to
the rear but that was incorporated
within the rear extension
and that was a flat roofed element so um
there is actually one well actually
there's there's uh
to the rear there's um there were five
proposed to the rear previously
now there's only two okay
and i take it that um that's not
overlooking the
the house that next door
no overlooking there um there there
isn't no we've obviously assessed that
as part of our neighboring amenity
impact
um we're satisfied that's an acceptable
arrangement all right
okay thank you thank you right thank you
um it looks like we don't have any other
questions oh you have one more question
is that from councillor jennings
yes
gentlemen um just one quick question it
was brought up earlier
about about bats and the bat survey is a
bat survey necessary on this or is it
is that uh not relevant to this case you
beat me too at cancer jennings i was
just about to ask that
sure uh thank thank you councillor um
about survey uh has indeed been carried
out um
and has been provided in support of his
application it's available on the
application file obviously technical
ecology consultants have looked at this
scheme in detail
and have offered um obviously given
their view that there is no
um unsatisfying impact on protected
species our county ecologist has
obviously looked
poured over this data poured over the
plans and
has uh recommended no objection um
to the proposal um obviously as was
touched on by by mr martinson that
obviously there is a condition included
within the consulting consultation
response
uh as has been detailed in my report and
your agenda packs um this is not deemed
to be
at the time in appropriate condition to
include given the scale of development
proposed
um i would remain of that view however
where that's to be an issue this this
could potentially be included as an
additional
condition merely to state that as is
stated by the consulting response it
shall be in accordance with that ecology
report that has been provided
okay thank you stuart berlin so in that
case
if we have no further questions we
should move to the debate
who would like to kick us off on this
one i'll look to the chat bar for a
second
don't rush it once of course
shall i start right go on i'll kick us
off
i wasn't at the meeting that looked at
this one before uh so i'm coming this
completely completely fresh
um my thoughts i'm looking at this and
i'm struggling if i'm honest to find a
proper reason to refuse
the building is there already and while
i completely understand the frustration
of the parish council and the ward
member in terms of
um the parking problems if this was
my view is if this was to open up again
as a church tomorrow morning they could
do so and the parking problems would be
there
so as far as parking is concerned i i
can't support that as a reason to refuse
this
in terms of everything else in my mind
it looks like bringing a local building
back into use so i would be minded to
support the office's recommendation and
grant the application
those are my thoughts i'm happy to
propose that
as a formal proposal so i will propose
that we that we do grant
uh excellent we've got some other people
joining in okay so uh you know in the
order they've been called
council mills over to you yes thanks mr
chairman yes
it's a difficult one for me it's a
difficult one um
all the um all the objections been
brought up
are exactly the same as they were before
and that's what
we um
refused it last time um
i'm i'm very undecided on this one mr
chairman
um not comfortable with it i have to say
purely because you know of this parking
situation i know you saying this is not
part of the uh
the application but i think it's
relevant to it i
i it it throws up the same problems as
he did last time for me
so uh at the moment i'm a little bit
undecided but i'll wait to hear what
everybody else is thank you very much mr
chairman
thank you thank you council mills
uh we move then to council uh curtis
next please
thank you chair um yes similarly i
i know this school quite well my other
my children used to go to the primary
school opposite
and there really is a major problem
with parking here and it seems
i understand that if it were a new build
um
then the the current arrangement or the
proposed arrangements for parking
wouldn't be satisfactory
and i i take the point that
it could reopen as a church and and we
would be
back to the sort of square one if you
like but given
that that isn't likely to happen surely
we we should be looking to
increase highway safety when the
opportunity
arises and i do think that with that
number of children
in that it is a pretty tricky junction
there
i think we do really need to take that
into very careful consideration
much as i i think the the opportunity of
having
a nursery there or in the village
is very sound the the parking and
associated
traffic issues do concern me thank you
thank you councillor uh move to uh
councillor jennings next please
thank the chairman and i echo what
everyone's been
saying here at the moment it's sort of
it's one of these
it's one of these situations where
um the traffic is going to be a real
issue here
um i know
if we if we if we do go down the route
of granting it and i don't know whether
there's any sort of you know
i would be trying to put as many
conditions as possible on this
especially as a wither as the officer
mentioned about the
with the bats in accordance uh with that
report
but i'd also be looking and i don't know
whether we can put any sort of
conditions on that about
the amount of staff they have there
because if they say yeah we're going to
have 12 staff but at the moment
then all of a sudden that jumps up to 15
or 16
you know we're just compounding the
problems i don't know if that's
something which we can do
that's probably something which um
the legal team will have to would have
to mention that
sound it's one of these very very
uncomfortable ones
thank you councillor can you can we ask
somebody to advise on this um
yeah alice is it best to go to you for
this one uh yeah possibly i'm happy to
feed in here mina can add anything
as she thinks appropriate and if members
think that it is only acceptable on the
basis of a sort of maximum number
of staff levels then that is something
we
we can potentially condition um i do
obviously have to say the usual that it
does have to meet the test so as long as
you think it is reasonable and necessary
and enforceable etc
then that is something we could
potentially condition
if that was was key to members nina i
don't know whether you have anything
further to add
just to say um i agree with what you
said there and just to remind members
that it's not
an application for a nursery in front of
you a change of use to a nursery
um as has been mentioned already by the
planning office that that does not
amount to development because it falls
within the same use class
under the legislation and so it isn't
constituting development
and so just bear that in mind as well
well i'm a bit confused there i mean so
bearing in mind
with big applications effectively for a
wall and some changes and alterations
it's not for the nursery
we are still okay to put a number of 12
staff
on or as a condition you're sure
if i can come in there i think i've
confused things by
perhaps being a bit more positive maybe
there than i should have been so
i think meena's absolutely hit the nail
on the head in terms of
there is no change in used class and
they could occupy this
site as a day nursery so as ever members
you have the gift to add whatever
conditions you think do meet the tests
but i think you would struggle to
justify it as being reasonable and
necessary given that they could occupy
it as a day nursery
as it stands uh the application does
only relate to that that enabling
development so apologies for any
confusion that i managed to cause there
that's okay i think it's helped me work
it out a little bit better actually so
okay so just to clarify what they're
writing saying that
if we did put a condition on like that
it could be something that would be
the applicant could appeal against in
terms of not being reasonable
yeah i think that's right um i think
actually we would be running a risk
putting a condition like that on and
things like the highways impact and the
traffic impact
of the development would be limited only
to this edition of the wall and the
fencing that's what the development is
in this case it's not the change of use
to a nursery
yeah okay i think i i get the message i
understand that we're being steered away
from that because it is not being the
soundest condition to put onto this
okay um let's go back to the questions
if that's okay
uh sorry some points uh councillor trump
you'd like to speak in the debate
oh i'm just making sure we were in the
debate still
thank you mr chairman um i might be like
alice another ic
i didn't add in some confusion to the
mata but hopefully
hopefully not um yeah i think we've got
to look at what's in front of us
um we've got the issues from highways
which are saying there isn't a problem
as such yes i went on a site visit um
previously um but
we have to be careful um going against
the highways authority i know we've
we've
done things in the past but now saying
this is not going to
cause any additional additional problems
so
very concerned about that and
unfortunately
an application can't uh
sort out resolve pre-existing problems
we can it's only if they're going to add
to this i think that's right stuart i'll
i'm sure you hopefully you're nodding
your head in agreement there
um but i think that you know we have to
be
careful that uh we can't be putting
conditions on we can't be making
decisions
on things that are not applicable to
this actual
uh proposal um it's it's
i know it's quite an emotive one um but
based on their presentations based on
what's in the report
it's quite close but on uh we'll go with
the officer's recommendation
and i'm happy to second cancer candles
proposal to grant this application
thank you councillor much appreciated um
okay we move to the next speaker tony uh
councillor dixon
thank you chairman um i was just going
to comment that i would have anticipated
that staffing levels would probably be
determined by the number of
children being there as though i'm sure
there will be some legislation
as to a ratio between staffing levels
uh trainers teachers child minders and
the number of children etc
um i equally well think that
to refuse it i think we would be uh
difficult to defend it at appeal
so i must admit uh councillor trump has
just beaten me to seconding it
but i was minded to do so thank you
chairman
thank you councillor dixon uh there's
nobody else indicating they'd like to
speak on this one
so uh i think we
should probably go to a boat we have a
proposition
and um a second i don't think we've
had we've not made any changes to the
conditions
so i think we're okay to go straight to
the vote aren't we so
uh and if you're standing by i'll kick
us off councillor kendall
four thank you councillor kendall
councillor fleming
councillor fleming for thank you
councillor crump
mr thank you councillor curtis
councillor curtis abstain
thank you councillor dickson councillor
dixon
four councillor eden
council redden against
thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings regrettably for
thank you councillor henshaw sarafin
council henches seraphin
abstain thank you
councillor mills council mills against
okay one two three four five
four two against two i've seen
thank you man therefore the committee
resolves to grant application reference
twenty slash zero two two zero
three slash ful with that we'll take
a i think we'll need to take a couple of
minute pause to get the next speakers in
and i can hand back over to uh
councillor richards
thank you two minutes a german
my
okay members uh we are back and ready to
roll if i could ask you please to return
to your screens
and we will begin again counselor
kendall thank you very much for taking
the chair for the previous application
is greatly appreciated and a fantastic
piece of sharing it was too
right we are on to application number
201667
ful that is garage block hartford road
in ulster
our presenting officer is sarah chadwick
sarah whenever you're ready please do
begin
thank you chair let's get my powerpoint
up
can everybody see that and can everyone
hear me i can see it and i can hear you
perfect thank you
thank you chairman the application site
is a brownfield site within the built-up
area boundary of the town of ulster
the site is level has an area of around
0.12 hectares and is currently occupied
by 24 vacant lock-up garages
it is accessed via an existing private
vehicular access from hartford road
and the site is banded on all sides by
residential development as can be seen
here
this is a full planning application for
the erection of four dwellings with
associated bin collection point
hard surfacing and landscaping
off-street parking is provided to the
front of each of the proposed dwellings
the elevations can be seen on this slide
the dwellings are terraced with each
having three bedrooms and a small home
office
the four drawings all feature porches
and chimneys and will extend to a height
of 8.5 meters
now have some sight photos here we stood
on hartford road looking in an easterly
direction towards the site and the
existing access
here we face in an easterly direction
towards the dwellings on seymour road
and the garages can be seen in the
foreground
finally this image is taken from within
the site looking back towards the site
entrance with the access
and the dwellings and hartford rose seen
in the background
chairman the principle of development is
acceptable as is the design impact on
neighbouring immunity and highway safety
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the application subject to the
conditions as detailed in the agenda
thank you sarah thank you very much
we will move straight into our speakers
we have no parish or town council
speakers and no objectors so
we will be hearing from our agent who is
mr steve
bromley mr bromley can you hear us you
may need to press start and six to
unmute so that we can hear you
we can we heard you briefly there uh
i'll speak again can you hear me
chairman we can indeed mr bromley thank
you very much for joining us
um you have three minutes we will give
you a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready please do feel
free to start
right thank you chairman uh the garage
site currently represents
an unattractive and environmentally
degraded site
can you hear me chairman we can indeed
yeah sorry you were talking i didn't
know if you could hear me it does not
provide a positive contribution to local
character
i note the comments of the town council
regarding the height of the development
however the proposed design is
traditional standard two-story terraced
housing
and it's very similar in height to
neighbouring housing
the proposal is very similar in scale
and designed to a scheme for five
terraced houses
that at a nearby garage site in illauna
avenue in ulster that was granted
planning permission
by this committee in march of this year
the density of the proposed development
is in keeping with the surrounding
area and the proposals fully comply with
the council's policies for separation
distances
provision of private immunity space and
provision of allocated
and visitor parking spaces in relation
to the access
transport consultants have confirmed
that in the last five years
there have been no recorded traffic
accidents in the vicinity of the access
they also confirm that in comparison
with the recent uses of the site
as lock-up garages the development will
result in a
reduction in traffic the highway
authority have confirmed they have no
objection to the means of access
and i would add also add that there are
no objections from warwickshire county
council
fire and rescue now although not a
planning consideration
representations have been made about
retaining access to the rear of
neighbouring properties
the applicant has taken this on board by
proposing a layout
that ensures vehicle access to the rear
of neighbors
neighbors properties will not be
obstructed
the proposals also incorporate a range
of measures that will reduce
impacts on climate change including
cycle storage sheds electric vehicle
charging points
main living rooms for each dwelling
positioned on the south elevation
to benefit from solar gain small study
rooms to aid home working
photovoltaic panels on the roof for
green energy
permeable paving for car parking spaces
footpaths and patios
to reduce surface water runoff rates and
trees provided in rear gardens to
provide
shade and cooling during hot weather 30
seconds
thank you the proposals are for
development of previously developed land
in a highly sustainable location
within the built-up area boundary of
ulster the development is well designed
fully complies with the council's
planning policies
and there are no objections from
statutory consultees
chairman i ask that the committee
supports the officer's recommendation
and grant planning permission thank you
chairman
mr bromley thank you thank you very much
for that if you just bear with us online
for a second while i seek
if there are any questions from our
members members if you could indicate
please in the chat
counselor mills has a question for you
casa mills
thanks mr chairman uh hello mr bromley
um
the um town council are
uh object questioning the height and you
said the height is similar
to uh other buildings in that area
similar are they is it higher are they
lower or the same
you said similar yes right
we spent a fair bit of time on this
issue councillor
um first of all the applicant is
proposing to reduce ground levels across
the site by about 300 millimeters
so the the actual height of the proposed
dwellings
is 8.5 meters
8.4 meters reducing ground levels by
0.3 of a meter that brings the the
relative height down to 8.1 meters
and we understand from talking to the
planning officer that the height of
properties in the area is approximately
seven and a half meters so the
difference in height between what we're
proposing
and surrounding houses will be
about 0.5.6 of a meter
so they'll be very similar in height
to surrounding houses
so so they that so they're they will be
higher
there will be very slightly higher yes
but i would point out of course that
these are set back
uh and so when viewed from the street
scene they will appear
much lower because of distance
okay i i think we've had the question
answered there thank you very much for
that and we have another question for
you please um from councillor curtis
council curses
thanks mr romney i just want to um can
you tell
let us know just a point of
clarification how long the garages
have been vacant how long of the garage
has been vacant
right um it's in the planning statement
which i'd have to very quickly look at i
think we do have that somewhere
if you just bear with me a moment thank
you
oh yes it's in there isn't it yeah
right there
okay the information we've been given
from
orbit housing last occupied 30th of
november 2018
november 2018 um two years ago
okay well i just wanted because you
mentioned that there hadn't been any
traffic incidents in the last
five years i just wonder uh how long the
garages have actually been
vacant forms so thank you for that
clarification thank you
lovely thank you councillor curtis um mr
romney there are no further speakers
indicating so
uh i will thank you for your time
contribution this evening if you'd like
to continue watching on the live stream
that would be great but thank you very
much thank you
members i admitted to say earlier my
apologies for that
there was a representation from ulcer
town council it is in the update sheet
you have all read the update sheet as
confirmed earlier but i just thought i'd
draw your attention to that if you want
to refresh your memory
uh very quickly now then please do um
it'll be remiss of me to ignore that
okay our next speaker then is juniors
counselor juniors are you there
yes sir i am indeed fabulous
i think um
council junior just just bear with us
we'll ask you to speak in just a second
so i just
need to run through that you have five
minutes and we will give you a 30 second
warning
um and when you're ready then you please
do begin
thank you um the australian council um
asked me to let you know that they were
unable to
attend to do today due to other
commitments but they did ask me to
uh talk about their uh objections
uh and i have their permission to um to
talk to you about their objections they
had serious concerns now everybody
accepts that the garage site
does need uh to to be developed because
it is otherwise a a a rather
um scrappy area but they have
serious concerns about the height of the
buildings
the they also uh feel very strongly
that policy hba eight of the ulster
neighborhood development plan should be
afforded significant weight
that one states that development
proposals must demonstrate a high
standard of design that's sensitive to
the area
be compatible with the distinctive
character of the area
be of identity and scale that is in
keeping with the character of the
surrounding development and landscape
and it is the height of the houses
particularly that they will
overlook the neighboring houses
that they have strong objection to they
also have
um objection to the fact that um the
the site is accessed by a very narrow
um access road they when
there's a lot of people use these a lot
of houses
use this area both to access their
parking
or to their back gardens or to their
garages i think there will be
quite a lot of traffic going in and out
and a lot of conflict uh
within that area because of the the um
rather character strong uh and um
character
uh that you know the density of the of
the development
i'm also very concerned about the fire
safety and exit issues
from from the area and particularly
about
adequate bin storage because again
if any of those bins end up being parked
and
accumulated in that narrow access then
there would be quite a considerable
problem but it is the over development
of the site
the height of the dual dwellings it
which are about a meter over
and would only fall down a fall within
that meter by the fact that site the
ground would be removed
um and dug down uh i i'd say a lot of
the neighbors are very concerned that
there will be overlooking
and they are concerned that it is just a
little bit too much of a development
had it been one house less or maybe a
slightly lower house
lower development um in stories then i
think people would have accepted it
so it is a matter of over development so
thank you very much indeed
thank you very much casa junaid members
do you have any questions for our
counsellor
i'm seeing a lot of shaking heads so i'm
going to assume that's a no so
council junior thank you very much for
your contribution do feel free to stay
on and continue to watch as we determine
this
okay um we will move to uh clarification
for officers members do you have any
points for clarification
for our case officer please indicate in
the chat
counselor crump
thank you mr chairman um sarah just a
very brief one
um in my other role um on portfolio
holder at the county for fire and rescue
um i'd be interested to see what the
note
was because mr bromley indicated in his
uh three minutes that the fire and
rescue hadn't objected
and obviously cancer junior raised it on
behalf of the town council that got
concerns about fire safety so
just some reassurance about that would
be be grateful please
thank you councillor i'm just trying to
find the response on the file
um i'm not able to see at the moment two
seconds
okay i've found it um there's no
objection subject to the application the
inclusion of an advisory note drawing
the applicant's attention to the need
for the development to comply with
um it's a very standard condition um
requiring a minimum width of an access
with the gateways minimum turning circle
these are minimum carrying capacity
um yeah that's pretty much it
so yeah just come so yes it's almost
like a standard response and like
no no i would say so yes unless alice
has any other further comments to add to
this
yeah i think it's a pretty standard
condition uh no sorry
yeah just just to clarify i've just had
to look at the the fire rescue response
um absolutely it is sort of our standard
uh consultation response
um obviously it set out a number of uh
provisions that need to be complied with
and we're satisfied that the plans do
allow for those to be
um complied with uh hence the reason for
the no objection from fire and rescue
thank you lovely thank you all for that
um counselor dixon
thank you chairman uh sarah could you
possibly put the slide up please
showing the plan because there was
reference made to
overlooking from on the neighbors
because of the height
just wanting to just revisit the scale
of the uh
position of their houses and where they
could possibly be any
overlooking as such is that the plan
you're referring to councillor
that's the one if we could just leave
this
thank you very much and counselor mills
has a question for you as well please
counsel actually man
we've virtued the same uh question as
tony so uh
i'll bypass on that thank you i'll pass
on that
okay no problem at all um i see no
further questions in
uh or requesting four questions in our
chat so uh we will move into the debate
who would like to start please indicate
in the chat counselor jennings please
come in
thank you chairman well i'm looking at
this and to me it's sort of
very straightforward and i guess any
material planning reasons subject to
this
application i'd like to propose that to
regret this application
okay thank you very much council
jennings um councillor mills
yes thanks richard i'm just i'm
the height of this doesn't does concern
me that we're
it's all a meter over is it a meter uh
higher than the rest of the rest of the
houses around there
no they're someone's shaking their head
but
um yeah it concerts
i'll listen again i listen to what
everybody else says mrs chairman but i'm
just a bit concerned about the height of
this
why they didn't uh have it the same
height as all the other uh in that area
thank you
thank you councillor mills um well while
we uh um
or before we move forward um sarah would
you mind just confirming
the uh difference in height just for the
benefit of cancer mills and the rest of
us
yes sorry um so the
agent mr romney was correct the height
of the drawings would be 8.5 meters
i've measured off the the topographical
plans provided that the dwellings on
hartford road would be 7.5
meters in height on roughage clothes
they will be 7.8
sorry they are 7.8 meters in height and
on
a lorna avenue they're 7.6 metres in
high so there's some slight variation
um with those but yes 8.5 are the
proposed dwellings
okay thank you so at it's absolute
maximum it's a meter otherwise it's
slightly less
so it's immediate sorry mr chairman so
that's the meter
at its absolute maximum it is a meter
but that is not all the way across so
there are some at seven point five seven
seven point six seven
seven point eight but at the maximum
yeah thank you very much
no problem counselor dixon i wasn't one
yeah
thank you chairman the only ones which i
can anticipate seeing any impact on
are if you like the ones on that bend
immediately to the
south west of these uh houses i think
those are
potentially the nearest ones to the end
of the terrace
uh but uh if that is where the
point eight and the eight point five and
the naught point seven differences
uh i don't see any issue but certainly
i'm very happy to second the proposal
uh that was uh by councillor jennings
marvelous thank you very much councillor
hencha seraphin
yes it concerns me um can we
slide back again please there was a plan
slide
okay thank you what concerns me uh
there's no access for these two middle
houses they have to come through the
house
to get to the back gardens
i'm not sure i fully understand what
you're saying um i perhaps sarah could
show
the route to access all properties
they've got a front
access the two middle houses of the
terrace is that the only way they can
access their back gardens is through the
front door
i think i can clarify this uh chair
it's a little difficult to see on this
plan because it's quite zoomed out but
if you can see my cursor this is
shown as a gate so this is an access
path that allows access to
the rear of that garden and then
subsequently up here as well there's a
gate that allows access to this garden
that clarifies matters yeah that
clarifies that it just looks a bit over
developed for me having four houses in
there
looks cramped okay
uh thank you councillor
thank you chair um yeah i'm i'm very
sympathetic to this i
argued one not so long ago about
something similar in
stutterly um
i'm not sure based on all the report
though that whether or not we can
actually argue the difference of
overlooking for the difference
of a meter i think that's probably a bit
of a reach and if
fire and um highways are
okay i had that um sort of
argument overcome my arguments last time
around so
i am incredibly sympathetic but i don't
see that we've necessarily got
a lot to argue back with on this one
okay thank you councillor edwin cancer
curtis
thanks cher thank you
and can i just sarah can i just ask um
a bit of clarification from you if i may
i think you will
be able to help the the depth of the
excavation
that's proposed to ensure the houses
these properties don't exceed the height
they've been given
we've been given i think it was 300
no that that is what mr bromley said yes
i'm
looking at this proposed site plan now
i think chairman if you don't mind me
interjecting i think
that that could be something which we
could secure my condition
just to make sure that we have got that
levels detail obviously the agent has
stipulated 0.3 meters digging but i
think
for everyone sort of clarity and
certainty i think we benefit in adding
an additional condition on if members
are minded to approve
that requires the submission of levitate
level details prior to commencement
can i just come back on that chair yes
um thank you very much
um yes because i there have been a
number of developments
in the district fairly recently
where developers haven't adhered
to the proposed site levels and it has
caused really
major problems so that that that would
be my
concern that we ensure that those levels
those build levels really are strictly
adhered to
thank you chair no problem thank you
very much we don't have any further
speakers
uh we have had a proposal uh from cancer
jennings and seconded by councillor
dixon
before we go to a vote councillor
jennings um you've heard the comments
from casa curtis just now are
you you're happy with uh the addition of
that um condition
uh for the levels to be included you
just haven't got a problem with that
okay thank you councillor dixon you
happy with it as well
you are muted yes very certainly happy
jeremias
marvelous okay in that case again we
have no further speakers we will move to
a vote
the proposal is to grant in line with
the officer's recommendation and
including
a condition relating to levels we'll
leave the wording for
our officers i will start councillor
richards 4.
thank you councillor fleming catcher
fleming reluctantly for
thank you councillor kendall councillor
campbell for
councillor crumb cancer crump for
councillor curtis councillor curtis
four councillor dickson
councillor dixon four
councillor eden
council reading
epstein councilor mills
councillor mills against
thank you one two three four five six
seven
four two upstairs one against chad
marvelous thank you very much and so
therefore committee resolves to
grant application twenty zero one six
six seven ful in line with the offer
officers recommendation and the
inclusion of a condition relating
to levels marvelous let's move on to our
next application which is
twenty zero one four zero six f u l that
is one
b hillside road our presenting officer
is stuart flaherty stuart
whenever you are ready over to you
chairman can we just have a few minutes
to call in the speakers please
forgive me i thought they'd already come
in
stuart once your uh your presentation is
ready to go please hold fire and we will
get our speakers in
thank you chairman
uh
my okay members
um we are struggling to uh get
one of our speakers in the agent for the
application
uh mr spicer um our delightful committee
services are going to continue to
to try and bring him in uh what i
propose we do is continue
um with the with the application
presentation
we do have our first speaker councillor
fragile
from the parish and town council so we
can proceed through to then hopefully we
should have had
both uh the agent and also um the uh
our council representative in by that
stage
so stuart i'm sure
i i got there a bit quick earlier but if
you are ready whenever you are ready
please do go ahead
thank you chairman um can everybody see
and hear me okay
see my screen rather than
this application uh is seeking full
planning permission for the partial
demolition
of an existing dwelling and the erection
of a new dwelling to sit alongside it
uh this application site sits within the
boa stratfor navin indicated by the
black dots on this plan
here we have a red line boundary
indicating the application site
and the extent of the existing dwelling
here we have a satellite imagery
zoomed out version of the site itself
nestled here indicated by the
red arrow
here we have a composite slide showing
uh what is existing on site and what is
fundamentally proposed this is a
crude l-shaped uh dwelling
there is proposed to be a partial
demolition as indicated by this red line
here
on the plan on the right hopefully you
can all see that
and the erection of a new dwelling uh in
its place
in crudely the same position as to what
is being demolished
um we can see here that um
the new dwelling will utilize existing
dropped curb
um accessed off hillside road uh there
will also then be two
parking spaces created here for the host
dwelling that is currently an area of
grass and a tree um
here we have again a composite plan
showing uh the existing
north elevation uh in
context of the immediate neighboring
property here outside of the red line
boundary
and here's what is proposed uh this
element here
is the existing dwelling here is the
dwelling to be proposed for as viewed
on the north elevation
similarly then we have the west
elevation showing what
is in situ currently uh and what is
proposed i.e
the uh partial retention of the existing
dwelling and the
erection of the dwelling here uh one can
see they are
as near as damn at the same height as
well um there are a few lines on this
plan there is a blue dotted line here
provided by the applicants that shows
the extent of a previously proposed
dwelling
uh that was withdrawn uh earlier this
year
some photos now the site uh here is said
drop curb
uh and this fundamentally everything you
see here is what is supposed to be
demolished
uh a single story in modest bungalow uh
as you can see
um here is a photo taken from a slightly
different vantage point we're now
looking at parts of the dwelling here to
be retained
and this built form here to the left
would be uh demolished
and finally we are just stood um at the
back of the existing dwelling um
everything you see pretty much on the
left of your
photo there would be demolished uh and
we can see
a bigger pardon would be mostly
demolished uh and then there would be a
dwelling
uh erected in this space with rear
amenity space
um this proposal seeks to direct a
modest dwelling in a highly sustainable
location within a quintessentially
residential area
it is considered to be of an appropriate
scale and is otherwise in keeping with
its surroundings
bringing about contemporary yet
sympathetic design and improvements into
what is quite a tired appearance of a
bungalow currently
um please refer to your update sheets
members for an additional condition
that is proposed uh relating to highways
uh chairman the recommendation is the
grants application for the reason set up
on pages 21 of your reports thank you
stuart fabulous thank you very much for
that um we will move to our speakers
then um i understand councillor ian
frashley
is uh in our meeting councillor fragi
can you hear me
counselor fragility are you there
i saw your name pop up a moment ago so
i'm hoping you can hear us
it looks like we may have lost counselor
fragile
we will try and get counselor fragility
back in in just momentarily um
we are having a few technical issues
tonight as it would seem um uh
we have no objectives so uh our uh
registered speaker
for on behalf of the applicant uh is uh
mr oliver spicer the agent
we have made every effort to get hold of
him tonight
uh and throughout the day today
unfortunately we have not been able to
raise him
um so unfortunately we will have to move
on past
uh mr spicer as well um i would
like some guidance from our solicitor
very quickly um am i right to be able to
move forward
to uh councillor jenny for actually now
in lieu of councillor ian for actually
coming in
or do i need to wait uh until we have
managed to raise counseling fraudulently
i think um it might be an idea just to
wait a minute
um he was i saw his name pop up as well
um is he still on the participant list
do we know
i unfortunately what i don't see his
name on the participant list i do see
councillor jenny frantially on there
right okay councillor jenny fragile's um
board member so she's
in the list as um
attendee of the meeting counselor ian
fragili
was dialing in because he's speaking on
behalf of the town council
understood um counselor jenny fragile
are you there can you hear us
i'm going to take that as a no um this
is a frustrating
glitch in our technology this evening i
can only apologize to both members and
members of the public who are watching
we are going to have to take a very
brief adjournment while we have two
minutes to seek uh
our um our ward members counselor ian
fragi if you are there and can hear us
if you press star on six
on your keypad you may be able to speak
and we may hear you
um i'm not sure if you have come in on
the phone or if you have come in
through teams let's take it let's take a
two minute break
uh two minute adjournment while we try
and get uh our
uh two counsellors to speak if not we
will move straight through to
clarification and our debate
okay members by my clock that is two
minutes we have not been able to bring
in any of our speakers so we will go
straight to two points of clarification
with our officer members do you have
any uh questions for our officer please
indicate in the chat if you do
give you a couple of seconds for that
i'm seeing some shaking heads
no okay let's move straight to the
debate who would like to start us
off on the debate
counselor jennings
thank you thank you chairman uh i'm
looking at this and i'm saying
houses come in all sorts of shapes and
sizes
and in order to build houses sometimes
we have to be innovative
and i think this on this occasion this
is one of those occasions
um i therefore would like to propose
that we grant this application
thank you very much councillor jennings
um i will dive straight in and second
that proposal uh apologies counselor
edna cancer kendall who have just
finished typing and pressing enter
uh they have both indicated their wish
to second as well um i'm not going to
ask you to come speak at this point i
don't think there's any need to
unless there's anyone else wants to
speak um in any other way
we will move to our vote i don't see
anyone indicating they wish to speak
again
so let's move to the vote the proposal
is to grant in line with officer's
recommendation and the additional
condition in our update sheet i will
begin
councillor richards four
councillor fleming cancer flaring for
councillor kendall
councillor campbell four councillor
crump
council crumpfort councillor curtis
councillor curtis for councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor eden
councillor adam four
councillor jennings councillor jennings
ball
councillor henshaw servin excellencial
seraphim for
councillor mills councillor mills
for the unanimous chairman
fabulous therefore uh committee resolves
to grant application twenty zero one
four zero six ful one beast the b
hillside road in stratford haven
fabulous we will move then to our final
uh item of the evening which is um
application reference number twenty zero
two one two
eight lbc the stable house warwick road
pilsen
percy our presenting officer is robert
parker gulliford
robert whenever you are ready please do
go ahead
i have been reliably informed again that
i have missed our speakers i
do apologize i am very keen to get
things moving
we will just call them in give us two
minutes
okay can you hear me
robert we can and we're just going to
take a couple of seconds while we call
in
speakers for this one i believe we
already have our ward member
in we've got two other speakers we're
just going to call in so bear with if
you
get your presentation ready we'll uh
we'll give you a shout when they're in
uh hello chairman
hello who is that oh that's rob
ah hello we are still waiting for our
speakers just bear with us if you don't
mind
yes for some reason uh computers playing
up as usual
okay uh if you want to attempt to fix
that while we are
calling our speakers that would be ideal
yes i'm trying to get my presentation
open again
no problem yeah i've got a few minutes
rob i'm just going to mute you while
you're doing it because it's still a
live meeting
yeah thank you thanks son
chairman both speakers are in
fabulous thank you very much caroline
robert are you still there
have you managed to resolve your
technical
issues please tell me we haven't lost
robert
uh sorry chairman still having trouble
with
presentation and opening it i've asked
alice to contact me
okay but she's not ringing
okay we're going to leave you muted
because we are still live um
and uh if you can then unmute yourself
and let us know when you are working
uh that is great okay just
just one minute
robert that looks promising i can see
the presentation
on my screen now i can't hear you at the
moment you may still be muted so if you
want to check that you are unmuted
and as soon as you've done that yeah we
can hear you now and we can see the
screen
so you're good to know i'm sorry
chairman i can't see the screen
sorry technology
it's a joy isn't it no
sorry i can't see anything now
i'll tell you what could you press the
down says it says bad neck
bad network quality okay i'll tell you
what um
do any of our does alice have a copy of
the presentation
yes yes alice would you mind sharing
your screen and bringing it up
of course not i'll share it yeah if you
could share it and then we you can cycle
through the images
um i understand that we do have some
photos as well that will need to be
shown during
the parish council's um uh council's
presentation
do you have a copy of those as well
alice i do so i'll share those as well
fabulous i'm going to do it now in terms
of presentation robert you can just say
next slide when you want me to go on
that would be yup okay right
you're just going to share now
can everyone see that i can certainly
see it yes thank you alice
brilliant thank you robert whenever
you're ready please do start your
presentation yeah okay everyone's come
back thank you
um the application is for a single story
rear extension
for use as a garden room the proposal
does not require planning permission
since it constitutes
permitted development the application
site lies to the north west of pelton
hersey village
as identified by the black dot on the
plan
slide 2.
this slide identifies the application
site outlined in red
the boundary of the conservation area is
outlined in purple
with a listed manner and church
highlighted in red
slide three this slide shows an aerial
image of the area
the stable sits adjacent to the manner
and close to the great two-star
church which has 13th century origins
this layout with high status buildings
at the extremity of a settlement
is a traditional distinctive pattern
which characterizes many villages around
warwickshire
slide 4
this slide illustrates the sight
features in the mid 19th century
the manor church and stable sit as
landmark buildings within a large open
parkland
type setting with a drive wrapping
around the northeast of the rear
elevation
it is likely that the courtyard and
openings sat on the south side
with the rear being a flat plain or
featureless facade
as you can see in the plan on the left
and the aerial photograph on the right
very little has changed
um the stable block is shown to the
northwest of
the manor um and if you compare that
with the historical plant only one
building is missing uh
elongated uh linear type building that's
sat in front of the stables that's now
gone but more or less the historical
footprint is
is the same and remains legible
slide five
uh slide five showing it
is yes okay it's not showing my end um
this slide shows the front and rear
elevations
as existing the yellow arrow to the rear
marks the position of the proposed
extension
on the western side of the front is a
1970s two-story extension to the front
sits a post-1970s building with later
alterations
with dormers and in front of this is a
later
garage recently this year we approved a
small site extension
to the eastern gable this isn't shown in
the photograph
because it hasn't been built it's only
approved earlier this year
slide six
slide six is showing it is yes
this slide shows the rear elevation at
close range
the stonework appears to be 18th century
and constructed in one phase
apart from the assertion of windows the
whole elevation appears to be original
be in the back it is likely that there
were there weren't so many openings when
built
the plane austere appearance and linear
scale reflects the stables
status with the manner and responds to
many service type buildings in the rural
landscape
slide seven
the elevation join presents the design
of the proposed extension
it would be four meters long five meters
wide and four meters high
matching stone and tile would be used
slide 8.
this last slide shows the extension's
footprint the right hand side plan
illustrates the location of extension
when the overall complex
there are a number of updates for this
application which have been circulated
on the update sheet
it is recommended that listed billing
percent be refused for the reason set
out within the officer report
thank you very much chairman robert
thank you very much for
that um we will move straight to our
first speaker who is councillor tim
newcombe from the person hersey parish
council
mr newcomb are you there can you hear us
you may need to press start and six in
order to understand can you
can you hear me we can indeed welcome
councillor newcomb thank you very much
for joining us
can i ask you a question quickly first
um
uh are there two photos on screen now
we alice is just getting them ready for
you um and they will be up
in front of them do you need to refer to
them during your your speech
i will and i'd refer to um photo two
which is actually
the rear elevation first
and then photo one which is the plant
elevation
okay uh we will go to photo so we have
photo two is on our screen now if you
want to say
um which photo you want at the time you
want it
uh alice will bring that up for us but
we can see uh photo two right now
you have three minutes we will give you
a 30 second warning
um and if you could stay on the line
afterwards for any questions from
counselors that would be great
otherwise it's over to you whenever
you're ready thank you
the parish council has carefully
reviewed this application and hopes very
much that the planning committee grants
listed building consent for the proposed
garden room
the district council has never
previously assessed the stable house as
being curtis listed and has allowed
significant alteration to the building
this includes the 1970s two-story
edition
which extends to both front and rear on
the photo
two which is to the rear that's on the
right of that photo
and most recently in photo one
in 2004 a two-story annex and the
construction of a large detached garage
both in the foreground in our view of
the building there's no resemblance to a
traditional
former agricultural building or its
original function as stable
its original form and appearance have
been completely lost and the building
now appears
as a two-story traditional house of
which there are many within the vicinity
the addition of small rear extension to
such houses is common
in recently granting a certificate of
lawful development for the garden room
the district council
has already confirmed that the garden
room does not require planning
permission
only listed building consent as it falls
within the size
thresholds which constitute committed
development
the garden room is of sympathetic design
uh to be constructed in blue life
limestone and clay tile
and would be entirely subservient to the
main house
and in keeping with its character the
applicants have also removed the
roof lights which were one of the
concerns of the conservation officer
the extension is not to be centrally
sighted within the rear elevation
but offset towards the southeastern end
leaving a substantial distance between
it um
and the extension of the northern end
and ensuring that much of the rear
elevation was still
an uninterrupted linear form the garden
room cannot sensibly be moved any
further along
towards the end of the house as it would
look directly onto the rear of an
existing outbuilding
rather than overlooking the garden the
proposed extension would be at the rear
of the property
none of which is publicly visible the
extension involves very little
interference with the
fabric of the building as it would make
use of the existing double doors
opening from the dining room there would
be no change in the visual relationship
between the application property
and the nearby listed manor house as the
guide will
not be visible from the manor house
which itself has been subdivided
and extended including a large garden
room added since 2000
and we'll see ourselves not the impact
upon its funded setting
the proposed garden room is such a
limited scale the relationship between
the two properties
will remain unaltered we therefore do
not believe that this very modest
position would result in any harm
to the character of either the stable
house or the listed
manor house we therefore ask for the
committed support
for this application tonight thank you
mr newcomb thank you very much spot on
time i must admit that was fairly
confusing because i could see
on i could see you on the screen chair
and everyone
talking and uh okay
we're having trouble with it i'm just
gonna stop you there
the the issue we've got is um we are we
are broadcasting live it does take
time for uh the actual live movement
and speaking from us to upload itself to
the
internet and then distribute itself out
to you so there is always a slight delay
there's sadly there is nothing we can do
about that
um we did hear your entire
your entire presentation and we have
seen the photos that you that you had
indicated too
i'm going to ask our members now to
indicate in their chat if they have any
questions for you mr newcomb so remember
could you indicate now if you have any
questions i'm seeing a lot of shaking
heads
nope okay in that case mr newcomb thank
you very much sorry i should say
counselor newcomer
uh thank you very much for your
contribution tonight and your patience
with us um
please do continue to watch uh the live
stream uh
while we continue to uh with the
procedures of the meeting
okay our next speaker is our applicant
uh mr featherston dilk i'm hoping i'm
pronouncing your surname correctly
um if you are there you can hear us you
can press star and six to unmute
yourself
mr fellas and elk are you there
can you hear me sherman i can indeed
welcome good evening and thank you for
your patience while we've had a few
technical issues this evening
uh yes i'm afraid i had the same
troubles as uh councillor newcomb
uh it's a regular occurrence uh sadly um
uh but uh something that can't be
avoided
you have three minutes we will give you
a 30 second warning
uh before your time is up and if you
could stay on after you finished as well
so that we can
uh we can ask any questions that members
may have otherwise whenever you're ready
please feel free to begin
thank you very much good evening my wife
and i bought the stable house last year
to retire to
with our family we undertook
comprehensive due diligence
legal searches confirmed that it is not
listed in its own right
nor had it ever been said by the council
to be curtilage listed
the council had not required
applications for listed building consent
lbc for the for the original 1972
conversion
nor the major addition in 2004 officer
reports specifically stated that the
property was not listed
so we purchased the house on this basis
in june a certificate of lawful
development for the proposed gardener
was approved as permitted development
not requiring planning permission
however officers advised us to apply for
lbc saying that although the property is
not listed in its own right
it should now be assessed as curtis
listed being adjacent to the listed
manor house
the council's change of stance that the
house be carefully existed was a huge
shock to us
had we known that we would have
reconsidered our wish to purchase and
certainly
the price offered we believe that the
change in the officer's view
is unreasonable we have nonetheless
submitted this application as the most
expedient way of securing approval for
the garden room addition
which will bring much more light into
the house
curtis listening does not mean that the
stable house has any special
architectural
significance which would justify listing
on its own merits
we do not understand why officers now
recommend refusal
on the grounds that it would detract
from the building's identity as former
stables
why because you will see from the photos
on the screen
that any appearance of the original
stable building has long since been
overwhelmed by the 1972
edition of a large two-story gable
extension
and a linked modern residential annex
added in 2004
and a double detached garage the linear
form of the building has been lost by
these editions
with the end gable extending out well
beyond the rear line of our proposed
garden room
we now have a two-story house with
domestic windows with no retained
historic features such as cartway doors
or hayloft access other than its name
there is minimal indication of its
former use
part of the front elevation has also
been rebuilt in modern brick as well as
a photograph shows
mr chairman the council has previously
proved much larger and more
intrusive additions and alterations to
the property all
without lbc no site visit was requested
or made by officers prior to submission
of their report to this committee
addition of a modest gardener will have
no impact on its historic or
architectural character or significance
and always alter the visual relationship
between the house and the listed manor
house
we therefore ask please for committed
support of our application
thank you very much uh thank you very
much mr
fella stand up that is uh well within
your time uh members do we have any
questions for our applicant
please indicate in the chat if you do
not seeing any movement so i'm going to
take that as a no
uh so mr president thank you very much
again for your contribution this evening
um
i would suggest it's probably best to
continue to watch on the
live stream online uh but thank you
again for your
uh contribution this evening thank you
okay we will move to our final speaker
of the evening
which is councillor pena o'donnell
council o'donnell are you
there good evening chair yes i am
good evening welcome and thank you for
your patience this evening as well
i think you know the drill you have five
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning
whenever you're ready do please begin uh
before i start can i just check with
alice that is able
that i'm able to have the two aerial
photos up that were
displayed by the parish council during
their presentation
whilst i'm giving mine yes absolutely
they're on
they should be on screen now i think
that's um the one from the applicant's
presentation
i understood the two aerial photos were
the ones from the applicant's
presentation that you wanted sharing
while you were speaking don't worry it
was actually the ones from the parish
councils but that's
i think that's that's final i apologize
i have a good memory of those if you're
able to find them and bring them up
while
uh counselor donald is speaking that
would be great if not uh we'll we'll
carry on and counsel donald i'm sure
we'll be able to refer to them
more than ably with her uh with her
speech don't worry thank you anyway
alice
don't worry so can you see sorry can you
see the aerial photographs now
no i can just see the applicant's photo
rather than the panache council's one
let me sorry bear with me one moment
because i should be able to share this
so bear with me one moment
thank you guys i know it's been a it's
been a tough tech night for you guys
um we'll get there thank you
sorry it's only one moment longer
no problem
how was that perfect alice you are a
superstar
i got there with you apologies thank you
thank you
thank you alice penny uh cancer donald
whenever you're ready please do start
thank you very much chair um so
interesting no
site visit was made members of the
committee mr featherston dilk has
referred to the planning history of the
site
and highlighted that the council has
previously taken the view that the
stable house was not
cartilage listed however even
if we accept that the officer's current
view is defensible
all this means is that the property was
considered as being within the cartilage
of the nearby manor house
at the time of listing in this case
1952.
this does not mean that the stable house
is listed in its own right
nor does it automatically mean that the
property has any special properties or
qualities
other than the fact that the building
was formally an outbuilding
within the grounds of the manor house
however the cartridge listing status
does give you
the committee the control to ensure that
no changes are made to the stable house
which might detract from the setting of
the main manor house
or undermine the relationship between
the two buildings
in this case as mr featherston dilk has
noted
the original building is dominated by a
two-story extension
that extends beyond the original rear
wall of the former stables
and by a modern domestic style annex
directly in front of the front elevation
these non-original additions appear to
exceed the original elements
and the building presents as a two-story
traditional house
with modern windows instead of a former
stable building with traditional
openings and doors although it is
undoubtedly
a very pleasant house the original form
of the building has been lost and there
is little
evidence left of its former use which
gives the property any special character
i agree with the parish council's view
that very few people
visiting the site or looking at the
photographs presented earlier
will be able to establish its original
use
there is therefore little of historic
significance remaining in the stable
house
other than its physical sighting in
proximity to the former manor house
which of course the proposed garden room
would
not alter the stable house is also
separated from the listed manor house
by its long established separate access
close boarded fencing and extensive
mature trees
the two buildings appear as separate
unrelated properties
and the garden room will therefore have
no impact whatsoever
on the setting of the manor house as
such
you the committee can be confident that
approval of this application does not
set an undesirable precedent
this case can easily be differentiated
from other cases
such as modern conservatories proposed
to be attached to traditional barn
conversions
where they might well be an impact on
rural character
given its sympathetic design and lack of
harm to any heritage significance
the application complies with our core
strategy policies cs8 and cs9
in cs8 historic environment it states
that for proposals affecting a heritage
asset
we need to assess the significance of
the asset in this case
we can see that the building has no
special architectural significance
and we know that any historic
significance as former stables is
no longer apparent it will have no
impact on the adjacent manor house
therefore the garden room will not
result in any harm to the historic
environment
and so the application accords with
policy cs8
policy cs9 is also relevant this seeks
to ensure
high quality design the proposal is
unobtrusive
sympathetic to the main house and
constructed from limestone and clay
tiles
the proposal therefore also meets the
requirements of this policy
i put it to you members of the committee
that this couple who are in the golden
state of their life
and have found their forever home have
been made to jump through
a number of hoops with this application
they have cooperated
to the letter these proposed works are
very
modest i would strongly recommend
that the only common sense approach to
this moving forward
and to move this building project on so
that this couple can actually enjoy the
home they've worked so hard for
is to support this application i
therefore ask a committee to support
in approving the application in front of
them
donald thank you very much for that
members do we have any questions for our
ward member
please indicate in the chat if you do
a series of shaking heads yet again it
looks like there are no questions for
you councilor donald so
thank you very much again for your
contribution please do stay on uh to
continue to listen to deliberation
deliberations and debate
we will move then to questions for our
officer do members have any questions
for clarity
from our officer i will ask
one if i may robert could you could you
tell me the um
the the applicant has indicated that
some
previous work has been conducted without
the requirement for listed build
building consent because nothing was
listed according to their searches
can you tell me when uh listing was
installed and
if it was prior to these previous
consents being granted why
no listing building consent was was
required
um there have been a number of cases in
the past where
um people have applied for planning
position and not listed being extent
because
the extent of cartilage listing is not
well defined
it's not shown in any plan it's not
referred to in a list description
it's down to um interpretation the time
and from site visits and how things are
presented
um listening has been around for a long
time and it's referred to in the 1990
act so
officers have been aware of it legally
since since that date
however there hasn't been much advice on
it there's been case law but
the the the most recent advice is come
from english heritage and that was
brought out
um about a year ago
and it's much unclear now how how we're
supposed to interpret things
however if you do a land search um quite
often it doesn't show up that a
cartilage list a bill if it's under
different ownership or it's been sold
off
would come and the legal definition what
a
curtail listing is so mistakes
sometimes happened in the past um
things were vague or maybe agents
weren't aware of it and they submitted
an application and they were advised
maybe verbally submit a list of the
architecture but didn't but um
a lot of this happens i'm afraid um
okay so so just so i'm clear um
ultimately you're you're
you're making your decision based on the
guidance that was published a year ago
and
uh that is how you've interpreted this
yes it's it's
it's always been clear that um to be
courteous
listed it has to be within the cartilage
at the time of listing under the same
ownership
and be ancillary in use to
the main listed building and and to that
definition this that that forced under
the criteria
okay thank you for that so i'm pretty
certain that legally we are now making
the right decision
in asking for this to build an
application okay
thank you very much counselor jennings
my brain's melting after that one um
so again i was gonna ask and it was
about
the building's special interest and sort
of what was it but obviously
this isn't to do with this building at
all it's to do with the manor house
next door and this just happens to be
an old stable which was in its cartilage
and since then has been radically
altered
is that correct um
yes um it is a listed building because
it's covered by listing
it's not the principal listed building
but however
because um it comes under the umbrella
as the billing control we have to apply
the legal requirements to assess what
impact this has on the building's
special interest now we accept that this
building has been compromised
significantly internally and externally
by the modern alterations
but we have to look at what's left and
and what's of interest
uh my argument is that you can still
appreciate
and read um the historical form although
we we were not too
sure how it looked originally there are
no original stable
door pins wagon door openings etc as
as as the agent and owner has as
has argued so what we're saying is that
we're we're left with a fragment but
we're trying not
to make the legibility of the struggle
form worse
okay thank you council jennings do you
have a follow-up
you don't have to have a follow-up you
look like you might ask one
not not right now thank you okay no
problem councillor dixon
thank you chairman uh you were pretty
you went before me uh chair and asked
about the uh the listing etc
i must admit i'm finding the answers
very interesting bearing in mind the uh
the application that's been deferred
this evening is also in respect of a
listed building
uh so uh no question at this point thank
you
okay lovely thank you very much um
unless other members indicate in the
chat
uh we will move on from the points of
clarification
i will give you a couple of seconds i
think councillor jennings may want to
cancel journeys
yes um sorry a follow-up question then
how do we um
agree on what is compromised or not with
this building
i mean obviously it's been severely
compromised so far
um and how do we
assess how much more compromisation
would
would this pla particular planning
application would have on it
robert would you like to come back on
that yes
um
in in planning terms compromise isn't
isn't the real
accurate terminology we have to go by
whether or not
this proposal preserves what's of
interest to this building
if it doesn't preserve and causes what
we call harm
in this case we're saying less than
substantial harm
we're obliged not to support unless this
public benefit
so that that's the main consideration i
think
okay um i think it's for us to determine
now councillor jennings as part of our
debate and we can openly discuss that
uh momentarily so there are no further
questions uh
for our officer so we can move straight
into that debate
who would like to start us off
councilor mills over to you thank you
thank you mr chairman
yeah yes i mean this this certainly has
had some add-ons everybody says and
looking at the photographs i can see um
there's quite some new brick work
uh as well your modern bricks um
i mean robert i mean he's he's he's so
knowledgeable
um but um
personally at the moment i can't see
there's a massive problem with
this this with his another addition to
the house so um
i think i'll be going against the
officer's recommendation on this one mr
chairman thank you
thank you council members is that a
proposal to uh to grant the application
uh i bet it would be mr chairman yes
thank you
i will take that thank you very much uh
councillor dixon
thank you chairman uh councillor mills
has proposed i would
second his proposal um the
the modern windows in that that rear
facade etc
i don't see any damage being caused by
this this garden room at all
um it is a situation whereby it seems
that a new owner
has been caught out by somebody who's
been a little bit more meticulous
in assessing whether or not this is uh
within or not to be a listed building as
such
so i don't think we should compound uh
previous uh errors or etc but i do
wonder
whether or not in granting listed
building consent which is what i would
be inclined to do is uh basically
confirming the fact that we think it
should be listed
um i have reservations regarding that
given the number of alterations and
amendments
and uh additions that have already been
to this building
it's only caught because of the
cartilage and that just seems to be
a strange anomaly thank you
okay thank you councillor dixon
councillor curtis i see you've indicated
you wished a second you were beaten to
do it but if you'd like to speak please
do so
thank you i mean um uh robert said that
he um talks about reading the historical
form
of this building but looking at it and
as he says
there is no real visible evidence of its
former use at all
so and given all the other alterations
i can't really see any reason to refuse
this application
oh i think alex's point thank you chair
okay thank you very much um
uh i see no one else is indicated to
speak so i would chuck my uh mighty
penis worth in at this stage
um clearly we do need to give reasons
for going against the officer's
recommendation
uh you'll see on page 56 of your reports
that the officer recommendation uh is to
refuse
um because the the impact it would have
uh on the historic and architectural
character of the building
and that that would not be preserved i
can only assume
from the discussion that has happened so
far that members consider
that by virtue of the scale and number
of
previous alterations um including
the lack of evidence of uh or lack of
clear evidence as identified by the
opposite
of any other openings for the building
um
we are discussing uh that they do not
consider there to be any uh
harm to uh either the historic or
architectural character of the building
is that a fair assessment i can see a
lot of nodding heads
um before i ask council mills just to
confirm that that is
the reason for his proposal to grant but
i just want to seek clarity from
um alice cosnett that you are happy with
that uh as a reasoning
we can reword it if required yeah
thank you chairman no really good i was
worried to be honest so no i've taken
that down and
and yeah i'm happy that that sums up
what you've said and and that's
reasonable based on your debate
thank you very much councillor
councillor mills just to confirm you
happy with that
yes i am very happy with that mr
chairman thank you marvellous and
councillor dixon given you seconded i'm
assuming you're happy as well
yes lovely um alice do we need to put
any conditions on other than standard
uh robert um can i call on you for this
moment obviously we'd have the
implementation period the approved plans
and then
list of buildings special um conditions
rpg
usually we condition for samples and
details of doors and windows
that's it i think so samples of
stonework
roof materials and design details for
doors and windows
lovely okay um
have you got all that alice uh i'm gonna
move to a vote very quickly but
i do are you happy for wording to be
delegated to officers chair
i am indeed along the lines of what
we've just discussed yeah
brilliant thank you marvelous thank you
alice
in that case uh we will move to a vote
the recommendation
uh sorry the proposal is to grant
um for the reasons we have just given i
will start councillor richards
four thank you councillor fleming
councillor fleming four thank you
councillor kendall
councillor kendall for thank you
councillor crumb
caster chrome paper stein
councillor curtis councillor curtis paul
cue councillor dixon councillor dixon
for
councillor eden councillor eden for
uh thank you very much committee
therefore resolves to grant application
twenty zero
two one two eight lbc for the reasons
given
uh members we have one item i want to
cover under urgent business it is not an
application you'll be pleased to know i
just want to
uh you all to note that on the 9th of
december we will be putting together
a special meeting of this planning
committee that is to hear a specific
uh and rather large uh planning
application at dallas burton polo ground
so please if you would put that in your
diaries
you will receive notification from that
shortly uh it leaves me
to say thank you very much to you all
members officers and members of the
public for your contributions tonight
and thank you also for your patience
with us well we had a few technical
difficulties this evening and also my
own
uh technical difficulties i'll refer to
it as
but thank you all again and we will see
you next time cheers
thank you tomorrow peter
thank you thank you we are still alive